what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again with yet another
fire dragon ball super chapter i have
been loving this arc so far first
vegeta's new epic form and now the
reintroduction of one of my favorite
all-time characters in the series
meaning bardock goku's that of course
goku finally discovers who his father is
and we get to see his reaction we got to
find out bardock's secret past and it
changes everything about the present
events in the story so make sure to stay
tuned for this amazing chapter because
there is so much to talk about if you do
enjoy seeing dragon ball super reviews
and want to keep them coming make sure
to channel the saying within and smash
that like button like it was a heater
remember smashing that like button is
goku energy and passing is yamcha energy
so choose wisely if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future dragon ball videos before we
get into it i want to give a quick shout
out to the one and only rage shadow
legends this game just keeps growing and
they now have over 600 champions
including some top tier waifus which is
always my main priority but on top of
the champions they also have very cool
bosses like this dude guardian of the
void keep malek kevar he used to be a
priest of light until one night he
realized that there cannot be any light
without darkness this heresy got him
kicked out of his priesthood but he was
right though how would you even know
what light is if you didn't have
darkness this guy makes you think bro is
he a villain or a zen master seriously
one of the best things about raid are
the constant inconsistent updates that
keep the game interesting oh and since
it's october raids got a non-stop
schedule of special events and
activities as we approach halloween
we're talking big rewards tournaments
against other players special events too
you even might get brand new legendary
champions including a spooky halloween
champion and much more if you want an
even bigger head start all you have to
do is hit that link in the description
or scan the qr code right here new
players will get an epic hero chinoru
who is amazing in the doom tower 200k
silver 1 xp boost one energy refill and
the one ancient shard so you can summon
an awesome champion as soon as you get
in game you will find your rewards here
in your inbox for the next 30 days only
and now without further ado let's jump
into its spoilers and all we get a
flashback to 40 years ago and remember
monito recently said that bardock was
the one who saved him and granola so
this is going to be a chapter explaining
how exactly that crazy scenario went
down how a saiyan the race granolas were
to destroy actually went out of his way
to save him and monaeto back in this
flashback it's pretty idyllic the
cerealians are happy and living in
harmony with the namekians but then one
day the fire nation attacked and they
came in the form of saiyans working
under frieza along with other frieza
henchmen notably it was during the full
moon so that saiyans could use their
giant ape transformation for maximum
destruction we see a bunch of giant sand
apes wreaking havoc along with other
frieza forces we're told there weren't
many sierra leones and namekians to
start with so the invasion went off
without a hitch the old elder on the
verge of death made monito the new elder
and pass the dragon balls off to him so
they remained in existence before he
knew it monaeto was the last surviving
the meccan on the planet and he said the
serials didn't fare much better we see
one giant ape with a scar on his face
and of course most of us already know
this is bardock we recognize the unique
scar he chases down granola and his
mother to a destroyed building and then
little cute granola is so scared he just
passes out right away then another
sierra leone realizes the moon is
important and they shoot to destroy it
harming one saint in the process since
the blast scraped his dome the moon is
successfully destroyed piccolo style and
the great apes revert back to normal
saiyans unfortunately though for the
cyrillians this is not a huge benefit
because the saiyans are still strong af
compared to them even without their
transformations and the remaining sierra
leones get killed except granola and his
mom before we get to bardock and
granola's mom we do see that dude who
got a wound across his forehead upset
because of his cut and it's like dude
you just killed an entire people don't
complain about a cut on your head but it
goes to show that this was just business
as usual for the saiyans killing and
destroying was par for the course but
getting a flesh wound was an annoyance
we don't know for sure what would have
happened if he stayed a great ape but
luckily for granola and his fine mom he
reverted back to his base form after the
moon was destroyed as a result he's face
to face with granola's mom as she holds
her son in her arms and of course
bardock makes a baby with her leaving
her pregnant with goku meaning that
granola was trying to kill his
half-brother the entire time and of
course i'm totally kidding but could you
imagine anyways back to reality as slim
says this face-to-face circumstance
allows granola's mom to get a shot off
on bardock which grazes his skin and
rips off his shoulder armor the wound
and the sight of a mom holding her kid
protectively trigger a memory for
bardock and it's exactly what us
dragonball fans want to see goku's mom
is reprimanding bardock for missing his
son's birth and bardock dropped such a
goku line here saying that explains why
your tummy is flat again she gives him a
bit of a hard time but i'm sure say and
dads are pretty horrible in general so
she gets over it pretty quickly she even
brings him to goku and lets bardock name
him sidenote we see a cute little raditz
as a kid playing outside i mean he's so
precious right here it surprises me how
much i appreciate seeing radiss again
even if it's just for a moment like this
but back to bardock bardock appears to
be taken aback when he sees goku to the
point where goku's mom notices the
implication could be that bardock is
getting more in touch with his
sympathetic emotional side something
that's not obviously emphasized within
sans he decides to name the baby kakarot
so it's bardock's decision and the mom
loves it and agrees excited about the
name she hugs the tank in which goku is
floating saying grow up big and strong
my little kakarot which is just so
heartwarming and wholesome absolutely
love this moment and i feel like it
should be on a christmas card or
something even though goku didn't really
grow up knowing this family it's so nice
to know that it was such a loving one so
back to the present within the first
flashback i know this is starting to
seem like flash ception but back to
bardo confronting granola's mom in his
mind he's now juxtaposing and comparing
the image of his son and the mother of
his child with granola and his mom
understandably this makes him doubt
himself and makes him not want to hurt
them just like how he wouldn't want
anyone to hurt his family the saiyan
with the new scar on his forehead he
seems to be playing quite a recurrent
role in this flashback comes along and
tells bardock the mission is done and
they've been ordered to leave but
bardock says he'll stick around and
check for survivors so ironically he's
presenting himself as someone who wants
to kill people even after the mission is
done when he's actually the only one
wanting to save people the saiyan tells
bardock to be quick since frieza himself
will be there soon another interesting
twist then bardock senses what seems to
be an animal with a power level of 5 but
then figures out it must be a person
since its movements are too deliberate
this is such a small detail but i
absolutely love it it's simple but shows
bardock's deductive skills and offers a
cool creative way of reading power
levels turns out this animal was in fact
a namekian monato to be specific who had
been repressing his power level and
bardock was intrigued that he could
control his power level bardock is
actually very cool here as monaeto goes
to hysterically attack him while bardock
calmly stops his cane with his hand he's
actually holding granola here showing
just how much he helped him we finally
find out that granola's mom's name is
muesli but i don't think that's super
important for us in the story of course
monito is glad to see survivors and
offers them shelter bardock warns them
that frieza is coming and that they'll
have to keep hidden from his radar
bardock does get mushy when asked why he
helped them he just says he felt like it
i like it when characters don't make a
big deal of their good deeds like this
and honestly bardock has probably been
on the killing side way more often than
the mercy side so he probably would
reject the very idea of people looking
at him as a good nice guy anyways he
tells them to survive as long as
possible and monaeto asks his name so he
knows the saiyan who saved them and gets
the answer bardock he might have known
that bardock and goku were related
anyways based off of their appearance
but since he got the name vegeta will be
able to assure goku that that was in
fact his dad so we jump back to the
present with an understandably surprised
granola who's only survived this long
because of a saiyan's mercy yeah goku
and him are not brothers but he's still
the son of the man who saved him so he
probably feels bad about trying to
blindly kill him monaeto finally says
that goku and bardock look exactly alike
and goku has no idea if this bardock is
his father he says he was raised by
grandpa gohan on earth but vegeta makes
it clear that yes bardock is his father
and we finally get goku discovering who
his true father was he's surprised
saying really my father although goku
clearly wasn't curious enough about his
past to ask vegeta about his dad he has
been embracing his sand side more and
more thanks in part to vegeta and i
think he will be interested to learn
more about his dad at this point than he
would have been when raditz first came
to earth after all his reaction is not
the reaction of someone who couldn't
care less goku says he wished he knew
something about his dad but he doesn't
and vegeta says his soft-hearted nature
clearly runs in the family and although
at first you can't really say they were
soft-hearted they both had the potential
to eventually become more soft-hearted
given the right circumstances as we've
seen whether every saiyan giving the
right circumstances has the potential to
become just as soft-hearted is up for
debate granola then gets angry again
asking how come his mother didn't
survive after all in the flashback so
far she's still fine and then monitor
returns to the flashback before bardock
leaves monito thanks him in part by
healing his arm just as we've seen some
other namekians do it's actually lucky
for monato that he did keep bardock
around because he's able to detect the
heaters when they arrive really like the
way they incorporated the heaters in
this backstory at first i wasn't crazy
about the heaters but this makes it feel
like they're relevant to the history of
this universe and it makes me care more
about what happens to them in the
present too and just fyi when i say care
about what happens to them that doesn't
mean i want them to be okay or for good
things to happen to them it just means
that whatever happens to them now
carries more weight for me than it did
before bardock right away recognized
them saying the freaking heaters another
nice touch that lets us know how big of
a deal they are even 40 years ago
bardock explains their brokers and
they've set their eyes on this planet we
immediately see the relation to this
moment and the present since they are
talking about starting negotiating on
our price with the sugarians right now
for the planet and we know in the
present they've already made a home for
themselves on this planet elec only
plans to give one tenth of the price
they get for the planet to freeze his
forces even though they did all the work
this gives you a sense of how they
became so rich over time he even insults
frieza's men saying most of them just
want to battle and don't even know the
planet's true value even at this point
elec was very wary of frieza saying it's
just important that he doesn't catch on
to their scheme because he's actually
got brains and obviously the power to
boot even 40 years ago they were talking
about reigning over frieza's army so i
gotta give one thing to them they got
patience bardock finds out that they are
plotting to betray frieza and obviously
it's dangerous for anyone to know that
information because the heaters will pay
any cost to make sure that they don't
make it alive to tell frieza finally
granola wakes up and freaks out when he
sees a saiyan and that is what attracts
the heater's attention monito puts
granola back to sleep so again it
explains why he didn't remember any of
this but wow it sucks for him that he
just slept woke up and betrayed their
location and just went to sleep again
especially when we look at just what
betraying their location leads to
obviously he was just a kid and it's not
his fault but there's no doubt in the
future he'll probably blame himself at
least to an extent in the meantime
bardock puts a robe on and pretends like
he's about to take these guys out and
elect tells him to get on with it
bardock hesitates and tries to buy time
by saying the namekian used weird powers
so it might make sense to learn more
before killing him but elec is not one
to wait patiently he shoots granola's
mom leading to her death and this
although sad is an absolutely great move
story wise i was worried that granola's
vengeance would continue to be empty and
pointless when it was geared towards
goku and vegeta but now it actually
makes sense for him to be an avenger
because he has a target that totally
deserves it in elec after this flashback
suddenly granola and the heater seem
more interesting and relevant to the
story and actually care about both of
them more elect has no shame and even
tells bardock to kill the kid quickly
but bardock unleashes an attack instead
gas protects them and bardock escapes
with the others in the confusion so not
only did bardock save granola once but
twice even putting his own life in
jeopardy in order to do so it's pointed
out that they might have overheard their
conversation and alec is worried that it
will put them in hot water so he decides
that they will have to die gas is sent
to finish them off while the rest
prepare for frieza's arrival so we have
a very interesting setup for bardock vs
gas and the arrival of frieza too super
interesting stuff as far as flashbacks
go i gotta say in the present gas is now
remembering that day 40 years ago and
it's confirmed that he fought bardock
and not only that bardock gave him
reason to want revenge and made him
suffer indignity which is pretty hype
and begs the question what exactly
happened will we actually get to see
bardock fight of course gas did get
stronger since then which would make
sense otherwise he obviously wouldn't be
anywhere close to a threat for current
vegeta and goku however elect doesn't
want to take any chances like last time
and plans to use the dragon balls to
ensure victory they head for the second
and final ball and that is the end of
this great chapter and wow i said it
before and i'll say it again this has
been the most interesting arc for me
definitely preferring it to the morrow
arc personally and we still have
granola's revenge to look forward to
frieza's arrival in the past and
potentially in the present and more of
bardock how much better can i get but
anyways that is it for this one if you
did enjoy this review and want to keep
them coming make sure the channel is
saying within and smash that like button
like it was a heater remember smashing
that like button is bardock energy and
passing his yamcha energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future dragon ball videos that's just
the way it works these days and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you